how many little people you think there
are in the entire world probably I would
say a million everyone say a number I
would say a million hold on I maybe
higher I think million no way more I
would say maybe I would I want to say 5
million I'm gonna go up one I'm going to
price his right $1 dollar yeah I think
six Bobby okay he said 1 million I said
million K 651 th000 not even a mill
closest without going over D you could
just you don't go outside yeah I know I
feel like I've you walk around outside
you never run into any of them they
could be hiding in a bush I don't know
but you know or standing behind a
[__] fire hydrant standing on
somebody's
shoulder and you see a little hat above
a fire hydrant but like you never see
them no really growing how many can you
check how many are in the Philippines
cuz there a lot those are regular
Filipinos they're not yes they are yeah
those are your uncles are just regular
size my uncles are tall no no no yeah
there there's not there's not a lot like
give me the number of
albinos I've never met I've met one this
one one at The Comedy Store yeah you
know that guy isn't it so funny The
Comedy Store it's like a comedy club I
think has seen every type of person
everye yeah the the airport in the
comedy club features every type of
person yeah even more so Las Vegas
airport that wow the whole world yeah
the people watching is insane there I
love McCarron yeah because comedy is the
one thing that people can do like I've
seen at comedy clubs a dude completely
paralyzed yeah from the neck down yep
one eyeball moves laughing no he's a
comic yeah oh
yeah I was a crowd
member no I just move well you know like
there are Comics that you know we have
all kinds of people doing it it's kind
of great in that way to express their
point of view yes wait one in 20,000
people are born with albanism so that's
a lot more what's Al oh Al wow they're
never outside right no they can't be the
sun is like the Kryptonite right whoa
that's insane wow but 61,000 dwarves or
little people I'm sorry my bad yeah um
is such a shocking you know Brad even
says though he he said once that
dwarfism is the name of what this Asian
albinos I've never seen yeah Filipino
albino I've seen You' seen wow wow
they're like future people they look so
cool look at that little Asian albino
albino baby still cute oh so cute Asian
baby's probably the cutest of all the
babies I think so agree oh no black and
Asian babies black and Asian [__] cutest
babies ever okay what are the ugliest
ones you never go there why don't we
ever go to the ugly ones yeah give me
the ugly ones one of the ugliest baby I
saw friend baby recently and I was
convinc I I was like dude I don't care
how new you tell me this baby is he's 38
years
old the baby looked like he just looked
like worn down he was just like like he
came out being like God damn yeah my
[__] placenta was I
can we go can we go to Arby like he just
had an old feel and like an old face I
think when they're not his ears were
sticking out I I love fat babies fat
babies are the way to go I think oh yes
oh that's a well that's a little that's
too much that's a lot of [__] rice
cakes right
there L of Nom Noms yeah yeah a lot of
Nom Noms but sometimes when you mix the
baby sometimes they go wrong people go
we love mixed Asian white right or black
white right but like sometimes like if
you see a black white baby they have
like an orange afro freckles big upper
lip small little lip I mean they it goes
wrong wait that's like um ice spice
she's
hot ice SP who's ice spice who's that
you thinking a tea Tequila No you guys
the rapper SP kid [__] kids wait what's
her name ice Spy Kids ice spice ice SP
ice spice you know look at her you just
described her red hair with the freckles
oh yeah yeah I am not and she is so cute
that's not what I'm talking about but
that's you said red hair with freckles
yeah but then with like a upper big lip
small little lip that's what I she looks
like if Santino 50 Cent and uh and Annie
um from the musical Annie
[__] yeah yeah yeah she hot though she's
beautiful she's beautiful yeah yeah I
don't know who that is so the ugliest
baby we don't know yeah I think it's a
tossup I mean you know white always goes
both ways I've never seen an Iranian
baby M probably so cute probably cute
probably cute yeah yeah why why you
looking at me like that I don't know
man why would you look at me like that
when you say certain things D around the
room and look at I I Dart my eyes yeah
you're right
right